[Music]
one of my favorite movies of all time
was filmed here in the studio in 1985.
one of your favorite movies of all time
was shot here which which is that uh the
goonies the goonies we shot the shot
on this stage
yeah that's uh
considered a classic i guess big movie
for me and my my siblings i actually i
found a photo from my favorite scene
uh i don't know if they got it in time
but yeah yeah yeah
what's happening in this scene and who
are these characters well uh this is uh
a sloth there and chunk didn't it yeah
and uh the audience is like yes it is
yes yes
that's right so i wanted to ask you a a
personal favor if you would indulge me
it would mean a whole lot to me
personally and might even be cathartic
in many ways if if you would help
reenact this that scene and the goonies
with me
okay all right i guess so really
who
how do we do this who's who yeah i
figured i would i would play the
adorable and magnetic chunk and you
would play the deformed giant monster
i brought i have costumes i got
everything i got music all right the
script this is terrific okay great and
there's
there's cards there's cards here for me
to read off of you're live they're very
simple my lines okay and i am sloth i'm
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i like the suit that sloth is wearing
it's perfect yes you're gonna be great
you're gonna crush this is gonna be good
yeah here we go uh can we have a
sentimental type of music please thank
you
[Music]
sloth
[Music]
you're gonna live with me now
[Applause]
yeah i'm gonna take care of you
[Music]
yeah cause
i love you
i love you
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody